- One.
Two. (clapping)
Three.
Four.
- [Woman] Good job.
- Five.
- Six.
My name is Eilat Nahum,
I'm owner and administrator
of Beit Shalom.
Beit Shalom basically mean house of peace,
and it's RCFE, residential
care facility for the elderly.
- You see people that have
been professors at UCLA,
doctors, pilots, and all of a sudden,
they can't walk, they forget their name,
it's hard to watch and to know that
it's just a matter of
time before I get there,
before my mother gets there,
before my grandmother gets there.
It's been a few years of
a lot of reality checks
on a daily basis.
So this second facility
is just down the block
from our first place.
- This house has been
a big blessing for us,
my mother-in-law got very, very sick,
and I wanted to bring her
here, so in order for me
to bring her here, I
had to have a facility
with the right staff,
with the right caregivers,
and I got my license.
Two weeks later, she passed away.
So this is like the
memory of my mother-in-law
and also it's been a big
blessing for all of us.
How are you, Mama?
How is everything?
- Most things are okay.
- Good, good, I'm happy.
- So basically, we have 24 clients,
one of them is Elsie,
she does beads, flowers,
and beautiful art.
- This was my hobby of
making beaded flowers.
- How long does it take
you to make one of these?
- Oh, well...
Some time.
- Taking care of the
elderly is very rewarding,
especially when they improve.
Some of them come here
and they are quite frail
and I see how they
progress and they actually
become healthier, participate for--
- How are you? (kisses)
How is everything?
- Good.
- We also have another
client, her name is Loella.
When she first moved into
our place, she was not able
to walk, or talk, or eat even.
Now, thank God she's eating,
walking, and talking.
And she's so happy.
- What letter is this one?
- What letter is that?
- [Man] H.
- That's right.
And this one is?
- I.
- In the afternoon, basically
we do bingo, puzzles,
arts and craft, because
it's very good for their
cognitive skills.
- Got a PhD and taught at Washington State
and then UCLA, retired
professor from there.
If you're not used to living
in an institutional care,
it's adjustment, it would
be good to have more younger
people have some experience
with facilities like this.
- Can you put H back? Where's H?
No, no, no, don't eat it. (laughs)
- The challenge in this job,
it is when people decline.
And they actually see
how they deteriorate,
you find yourself being really helpless.
- Let's get them out and
then dinner going also.
Today, they have a special treat.
You gonna have dinner?
(speaks foreign language)
Dinner!
- I feel the elderly are neglected a lot
by their own families,
and it's sad because
elderly kind of want to have
their own family around.
- I have some family members
who don't even visit,
and that's the sad part and
sometime we try to call them,
to speak to them, they
don't even answer the phone.
- I haven't been happy since my wife died,
my daughter died, and my son
ran off with all the money.
So, ain't been too many happy days.
- That's one of the things,
it really hurt me deep inside.
Just take the moment and
come and visit your parents.
If it was the other way around,
your parents would come and visit you.
One parent can take care of 10 kids,
10 kids cannot take care of one parent.
- When I was living on my own,
I used to celebrate the holidays,
and I would always call up
nursing homes and ask them
to please send me a few of their people,
so that their people could
then enjoy the holidays
to their fullest and not
spend it lonely in a room
by themselves.
Please remember the elders,
because they have contributed
so much to all of our lives.
- I had a client and I'd ask him,
"Sheldon, is there anything that you need,
"do you want me to do anything for you,
"is there any food you want
me to pick up for you,"
and he said,
"No, just please, if you
could come and talk to me. "
- One, two, three, four--
("This Little Light of Mine")
- Just visit your
grandparents, visit your aunt
who's 90 years old, who's home
by herself with a caregiver,
and have a conversation with
them, spend 10-15 minutes
with them and you will
see how much they thrive.
♪ I'm gonna let it shine ♪
♪ Everywhere I go, I'm
gonna let it shine ♪
- There is a beautiful, beautiful psalm
in the book of Psalms,
which King David wrote,
that says, in Hebrew,
(speaks in foreign language)
which translates to, "Don't cast me away,
at old age, and when I lose
my strength and my ability,
don't let me go."
And I live by that sentence,
it's meant for our parents
and for our loved ones, when they get old,
to not throw them away,
to not cast them away,
to not let go, but to be there for them,
especially in the last
years of their lives,
to nurture them, to take care of them,
and when it's your time, people
will do the same for you.